so there are two groups of people
uh pressuring meta on this one group is
upset that facebook
the social network allows misinformation
and quotes to be spread on the platform
the other group are concerned that
facebook censors speech
by calling it misinformation so you're
getting it from both sides
you uh in 2019 october
at georgetown university eloquently
defended the importance of free speech
but then covet came
and the 20 and the 2020 election came
do you worry that outside pressures from
advertisers politicians the public have
forced meta to damage the ideal of free
speech that you spoke highly of
just to say some obvious things up front
i don't think pressure from advertisers
or politicians directly in any way
affects how we think about this i think
these are just hard topics um
so let me just take you through our
evolution from kind of the beginning of
the company to where we are now um you
don't build a company like this unless
you believe that people expressing
themselves is a good thing
right so that's sort of the the
foundational thing you can kind of think
about our company
as a formula
where we think giving people voice and
helping people connect creates
opportunity right so those are the two
things that we're always focused on are
sort of helping people connect we talked
about that a lot but also giving people
voice and ability to express themselves
then by the way most of the time when
people express themselves that's not
like politically controversial content
it's like
expressing something about their
identity that's more related to the
avatar conversation we had earlier in
terms of expressing some facet but
that's what's important to people on a
day-to-day basis and sometimes when
people feel strongly enough about
something it kind of becomes a political
topic
that's sort of always been a thing that
we've focused on
there's always been the question of
safety in this
which you know if you're building a
community i think you have to focus on
safety we've had these community
standards from early on and there are
about
20 different kinds of harm that we track
and try to fight actively we've talked
about some of them already so it so it
includes things like bullying and
harassment um it includes things like um
like terrorism or promoting terrorism um
inciting violence intellectual property
theft and in general i think call it
about 18 out of 20 of those
there's not really a particularly
polarized definition of that um you know
i don't i think you're not really going
to find many people in the country or in
the world um who are trying to say we
should be um
fighting terrorist content less
i think that the the content where there
are a couple of areas where i think this
has gotten more controversial recently
which i'll which i'll talk about um and
you're right that misinformation is is
basically is is is up there and i think
sometimes the definition of hate speech
is up there too
um but i think in general
most of the content that that that i
think we're working on for safety
is is not actually you know people don't
kind of have these questions so it's
sort of this this subset
but if you go back to the beginning of
the company
this was sort of
pre-deep learning days
and
therefore and you know i was it was me
and my roommate dustin joined me
and
um
and like
if someone posted something bad
um you know it was
the ai technology did not exist yet to
be able to go
basically look at all the content um
and
we were a small enough outfit that no
one would expect that we could review it
all even if like someone reported it to
us we basically did our best right it's
like someone would report it and we'd
we'd try to look at stuff and and
and deal with stuff and
for cult the first um
i don't know
seven or eight years of the company
you know we weren't that big of a
company you know for a lot of that
period we weren't even really profitable
the ai didn't really exist to be able to
do the kind of moderation that we do
today
and then at some point
in kind of the middle of the last decade
that started to flip and we um you know
we became it got to the point where we
were
sort of a larger and more profitable
company and the ai was starting to come
online
to be able to proactively detect some of
the
simpler forms of this so things things
like pornography you could train an
image classifier to you know identify
what a nipple was or you can fight
against terrorist content you still
actually papers on this is great oh of
course technical papers of course there
are you know those are relatively easier
things to train ai to do
then for example understand the nuances
of what is inciting violence in a
hundred languages around the world and
um not have the false positives of like
okay
are you posting about this thing that
might be inciting violence because
you're actually trying to denounce it
in which case we probably shouldn't take
that down where if you're trying to
denounce something that's inciting
violence um
in in some kind of
dialect in a corner of india um as
opposed to okay actually you're posting
this thing because you're trying to
incite violence okay building an ai that
can basically get to that level of
nuance and all the languages that we
serve um
is something that i think is only really
becoming possible now not not towards
the middle of the last decade but
there's been this evolution
and i think what happened um
you know people sort of woke up after
and
you know a lot of people like okay this
the country is a lot more polarized
there's a lot more um stuff here than we
realized um
why weren't these internet companies on
top of this
and
i think at that point
it was reasonable feedback
that you know some of this technology
had started becoming possible and at
that point i really did feel like um we
needed to make a substantially larger
investment we'd already worked on this
stuff a lot on ai and on these integrity
problems but that we should basically
invest
you know have a thousand or more
engineers basically work on building
these ai systems to be able to go and
proactively identify the stuff across
all these different areas
okay so we went and did that now we've
built the tools to be able to do that
and now i think it's actually a much
more complicated set of philosophical
rather than technical questions which is
the exact policies which are okay now
we the way that we basically
hold ourselves accountable
is we issue these transparency reports
every quarter and the metric that we
track is for each of those 20
types of of um of harmful content how
much of that content are we taking down
before someone even has to report it to
us right so how effective is our ai at
doing this
but
that basically creates this big question
which is okay now we need to really
be careful about how proactive we set
the ai and where the exact policy lines
are around what we're taking down
it's
certainly at a point now
where
you know i felt like
at the beginning of that journey of
building those ai systems
there's a lot of push they're saying
okay you've got to do more there's
clearly a lot more bad content that that
people aren't reporting um or that
you're not getting to and you need to
get more effective at that and i was
pretty sympathetic to that but then i
think at some point along the way there
started to be almost equal issues on
both sides of okay actually you're kind
of taking down too much stuff right or
or some of this stuff is is borderline
um and and it wasn't really bothering
anyone and they didn't report it um
so is that is that really an issue that
you need to take down um whereas we
still we still have the critique on the
other side too where a lot of people
think we're not doing enough
um
so it's become
as we built the technical capacity i
think it becomes
more
philosophically interesting almost where
you want to be on the line
and
i just think like you don't want one
person making those decisions so we've
also tried to innovate in terms of
building out this independent oversight
board which has people who are dedicated
to free expression but from around the
world
who people can appeal cases to
so a lot of the most controversial cases
basically go to them and they make the
final binding decision on how we should
handle that and then of course their
decisions we then try to you know figure
out what the principles are behind those
and encode them into the the algorithms
and how are those people chosen which
you know you're outsourcing a difficult
decision yeah the initial people
um we chose
a handful of chairs for the um
uh for the group
and
we basically
chose the people for
a commitment to free expression
and like
a broad understanding of human rights
and the trade-offs around free
expression so fundamentally people who
are going to lean towards free
expression towards freedom of speech
okay so there's also this idea of fact
checker so jumping around to the
misinformation questions especially
during
is an exceptionally speaking of portals
can i speak to the covid thing and yes i
mean i think one of the hardest set of
questions around free expression because
you asked about georgetown as my stance
fundamentally changed and the answer to
that is
no my my stance has not changed it is
fundamentally the same as when we were
when i when i was talking about george
talking to georgetown from a
philosophical perspective
the challenge with free speech is that
everyone agrees
that there is a line where if you're
actually
about to do physical harm to people
that
there should be restrictions so i mean
there's the famous
supreme court historical example of like
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater
the thing that everyone agrees disagrees
on is what is the definition of real
harm where i think some people think
okay this should only be a very
literal i mean take it back to the
bullying conversation we were just
having where is it is it just harm if
the person is about to hurt themselves
because they've been bullied so hard or
is it actually harm like as they're
being bullied and kind of at what point
in the spectrum is that and that's the
part that there's not agreement on but i
think what people agree on pretty
broadly is that when there is an acute
threat that it does make sense from a
societal perspective to tolerate less
less speech
that could be potentially harmful in
that acute situation so i think where
kovid got very difficult
is you know i don't think anyone
expected this to be going on for years
um but
if in in if you'd kind of asked now a
priori would a global pandemic where
um you know a lot of people are dying
and catching this
um is that an emergency that where where
you'd kind of consider it that um you
know it's problematic to to to basically
yell fire in a crowded theater i think
that that probably passes that test so i
know that's it's it's a very tricky
situation but i think the the
fundamental commitment to free
expression
is there um and that's that's that's
what i believe and again i don't think
you start this company unless you care
about people being able to express
themselves as much as possible but
but i think that that's um
that's the question right it's like how
do you define what the harm is and how
and how acute that is and what are the
institutions that define that harm a lot
of the criticism
is that the cdc the who the institutions
we've come to trust as a civilization to
uh
to give
the line of what is and isn't harm in
terms of health policy have failed
in many ways in small ways and in big
ways depending on who you ask and then
the perspective of meta and facebook is
like well
where the hell do i get the information
of what isn't isn't misinformation so
it's a really difficult place to be in
but it's great to hear that you're
leaning towards freedom of speech
on this aspect and
again i think this actually calls to the
fact that we need to reform institutions
that help keep an open mind of what
isn't isn't misinformation
and misinformation has been used to
bully
um on the internet i mean i just have
you know i'm friends with joe rogan and
he is called as a
i remember hanging out with him in vegas
and somebody yelled stop spreading
misinformation
i mean uh and there's a lot of people
that follow him that believe he's not
spreading misinformation like you can't
just
not acknowledge the fact that there's a
large number of people
that have a different definition of
misinformation that's such a tough place
to be like who do you listen to do you
listen to quote-unquote experts who gets
as a person who has a phd i gotta say i
mean i'm not sure i know what defines an
expert
um especially in a new
in a totally new
pandemic or a new catastrophic event
especially when politics is involved and
especially when the newser the the the
media involved that
uh can propagate
sort of outrageous narratives and
thereby make a lot of money like what
the hell who where is the source of
truth and then everybody turns to
facebook it's like please tell me what
the source of truth is
well i mean well how would you handle
this if you're in my position
it's very very very very difficult i
would say
um
i would more speak about how difficult
the choices are and be transparent about
like what the hell do you do with this
like here you go exactly ask the exact
question you just asked me but to the
broader public like okay yeah you guys
tell me what to do so like crowdsource
it
and then the other uh the other aspect
is
when
you you spoke really eloquently about
the fact that
this there's this going back and forth
and now there's a feeling like you're
censoring a little bit too much
so i would lean i would try to be ahead
of that feeling i would now lean towards
freedom of speech and say you know we're
not the ones that are going to define
misinformation uh let it be a public
debate
let the idea stand and i i actually
place you know this idea misinformation
i place the responsibility on the poor
communication skills of scientists
they should be in the battlefield of
ideas and everybody
who is uh
spreading information against the
vaccine
they should not be censored they should
be talked with and you should show the
data you should have open discussion as
opposed to rolling your eyes and saying
i'm the expert i know what i'm talking
about no you need to convince people
it's a battle of ideas so that's the
whole point of freedom of speech it's
the way to defeat bad ideas is with with
good ideas with speech
so like the responsibility here falls on
the poor
uh communication skills of scientists
thanks to social media
um
scientists are not communicators they
have the power to communicate some of
the best stuff i've seen about covenant
from doctors is on social media it's a
way to learn to respond really quickly
to go faster than the peer review
process and so they just need to get way
better at that communication and also by
better i don't mean just
convincing i also mean speak with
humility don't talk down to people all
those kinds of things and as a platform
i would say
i would step
back a little bit
not all the way of course because
there's a lot of stuff that can cause
real harm as we've talked about but you
lean more towards freedom of speech
because then people
from a brand perspective wouldn't be
blaming you for the other ills of
society
which there are many the institutions
have flaws
the political divide
obviously politicians have flaws that's
news
uh the the media has has flaws that
they're all trying to work
with and because of the central place of
facebook in the world
all of those flaws somehow kind of
propagate to facebook and you're sitting
there
the in
as plato the philosopher have to answer
to some of the most difficult
questions asking uh being asked of human
civilization so i don't know maybe this
is an american answer though to lean
towards freedom of speech i don't know
if that applies globally
so yeah i don't i don't know but
transparency and saying
i think as a technologist one of the
things i sense about facebook and matter
when people talk about
this company is they don't
necessarily understand fully how
difficult the problem is you talked
about ai has to catch a bunch of harmful
stuff
really quickly just the sea of data you
have to deal with
it's a really difficult problem so like
any of the critics if you just hand them
the helm
for a week
let's see how well you can do
like that to me that that's definitely
something that
would wake people up to how difficult
this problem is if there's more
transparency saying how difficult this
problem is
you